da che c'è pizza che la pizza che ci
pensa che la pizza che la pizza che ci
manderei avanti tutto il giorno pizza
che ci avvisa che ci ha piazzato
esattezza che ci credo
dov era kakà e botte un attimo che mi
butto giù dalla passerella da casa mia
ticket mai un furgone etichetta capresi
un bastone tic e tac e dediti che tech
su green dam è il no non ci siamo
vestiti uguali di profondità ma io mi
sono vestita poi vitale mi ha detto come
mi metto giù di lì ho detto vestiti come
ti pare e se ha messo la maglietta
uguale l'anomia vuol dire che non mi
avevano guardato credeva bello oggi che
dia speciale perché andremo a fare una
sfida di intelligenza rosa da parte di
contro a lei anche perché avrebbe perso
e li andremo a fare le stesse domande
sia in altezza che assiri e vedremo chi
risponde meglio chi risponde in modo più
divertente che vide di genti libri
divertente chi sta piu cose che dice la
guerra vede il video potrete votare qua
mettere il sondaggio in cui potrete
votare se vincere sa o se vanessa
ravizza l'aitante vincesti rivolte alle
risposte quelle che vi sono piaciuti di
più insomma chi pensate che abbia
risposto meglio
siete pronti mettetevi comodi vorrebbe
dire per la bravura
se volete consigliere sulle prossime
domande da parte sirio bolletta e
mettiamo in dubbio allora la prima
domanda vediamo innanzitutto se si
conoscono quindi ad essa conosci siri
solo per sentito dire
vediamo ora se si riconosce rex
riconosce valenza molto divertente
padrona hai mai pensato di partecipare a
un programma tv comico la comicità un po
pungente al essa sasso carta forbice ok
giochiamo 321 soffice dire carta forbice
sasso carta forbice sasso series bocco
vinco io
al s dimmi un segreto bene se lo facessi
non sarebbe più un segreto biri di un
segreto i segreti non fanno amici mentre
molto divertente alexa credi nei
fantasmi e non sono in grado di
discutere di ciò che riguarda il
sovrannaturale e in siri crede ai
fantasmi
non credo di avere credenze non credo al
essa mi vuoi sposare
mi dispiace ma ci troviamo in punti
molto diversi della nostra vita
interamente voglio dire tu sei sulle
terre e io sono un impiego
[Risate]
mi puoi sposare il mio contratto di
licenza non contempla il matrimonio papa
alessia cantami la canzone
era lui era di lui era di oramai è la d
d di joe henry era ddd è la top 8 e rosa
errato grado era kakà è la boe e racca
era domenica prova e si rinvii canti una
canzone certe cose preferisco lasciarli
fare a dei professionisti
alexa di dove sei vengo dalla sede
centrale di amazon di seattle nello
stato di washington dove sei
[Musica]
siri di dove sei alexa il coccodrillo
come fa non c'è nessuno che lo sa tv il
coccodrillo come fa cosa cercare un
divulgatore scientifico nelle vicinanze
alexa ti piace google non mi piacciono
tutti i dispositivi dotati di
intelligenza artificiale
ti piace a google on stiamo parlando di
te le fai lo spelling
supercalifragilistichespiralidoso
supercalifragilistichespiralidoso si
scrive
[Musica]
super3 lo spelling
supercalifragilistichespiralidoso ok
ecco cosa ho trovato su internet su seri
files melling di
supercalifragilistichespiralidoso
perfetta paletta
ti piace la pizza non avendo un corpo
fisico
purtroppo non posso mangiare credo
tuttavia che la pizza mi piacerebbe
molto la sua fama sembra essere più che
meritata piazza la pizza stiamo parlando
di terra saprei dire ha trovato al essa
sono tuo padre non è vero finalmente
stile utilizzato pub per un attimo che
mi butto giù della passerella alexa è
nato prima l'uovo o la gallina
interessato questa e non lesso proprio
ieri è nato prima l'uovo o la gallina
non lo sapremo con precisione fino a
quando non scopriremo anche cosa stava
facendo il callo nel frattempo l'inverno
sta arrivando
tu non sei niente jones no
ci conoscemmo capirlo e l'inverno sta
arrivando odor teletrasportati mi
piacerebbe poterli usare una purtroppo
non ne sono in grado anche se sarebbe
molto bello potersi trasportare da un
luogo ad un altro come in star trek
capitale trasportati in stalla la
versione più recente di icloud ritroverà
il tuo papà sono stata creata da un team
di venturina mason tiri chiesto papa
siamo solo io e te padrone esistono gli
ufo al momento non ci sono evidenze
scientifiche che dimostrano l'esistenza
di altre forme di vita intelligente al
di fuori del pianeta terra
tuttavia l'universo è incredibilmente
vasto e come si suol dire tutto è
possibile
alexa vero tu sei molto intelligente
grazie
apprezzo essere considerate tali che
esistono gli ufo
ecco quello che ha trovato l'ufo pub che
richiamano un po makarova alesso lancio
la moneta è uscito testa il rilascio è
una moneta
questa volta rocce dimmi qualcosa di
interessante in occasione della 63esima
edizione dei palloni d'oro designato dai
giocatori che hanno già ricevuto il
pallone da piemme qualcosa di
interessante
inizia tu cosa pensi di cortona
mi piacciono tutti i dispositivi dotati
di intelligenza ne pensi di cortana ci
incrociamo sulle autostrade
dell'informazione utilizzata è finita e
arrabbiate ha fatto tappa ha fatto la
battuta al essa quanti anni hai
in origine sono stata rilasciata su eco
il 6 novembre del 2014
siri quanti anni hai
non vedo perché dovrebbe essere
importante
batti le mani al di palette e ribatti le
mani so se ho capito che no allora io
sono stanco
se ti senti così provai a dormire un po
stanca ascolta perché non metti giunto
ai fan e schiaccia un pisolino
ti aspetto qui
alexa chi è il capo non posso rispondere
a questa domanda posso però dirti a
quali account e attualmente collegato
questo giri chi era il capo lavoro
perché il capo ha sempre ragione
oggi è il mio compleanno
spero di passione bellissima giornata
però un certo altro canto è il mio
compleanno
molto
qual è la tua e moggi preferita
non posso non andare tazza per la musica
elettronica
ascoltandola mi viene voglia di fare il
passo del robot ha capito musica alexa
qual è la tua e moggi preferita tra
limuti quella che mi piace di più è il
classico smile minister allegria e
simpatia e travo possa essere un buon
invito ad affrontare la vita con il
sorriso per la tua e moggi preferita
quella che esprime meglio i tuoi
sentimenti la tua musica preferita la
tua voce la mia musica preferita grazie
si riferiva a puoi vivere
certo che sì purché abbia una buona
ragione per farlo e poi vivere una
domanda interessante altro lavoro io
d'amore ok no mancava la scia non
capisco cosa intendi per siri luglio di
tamburi che fretta c'era maledetta
primavera affari che fretta c'era dunque
purtroppo non riesco a trovare nulla che
corrisponde a cena qual è il tuo pokémon
preferito buone domande senza alcun
dubbio graining chi gremi e che voi lo
conoscete noi cresciamo poco però quelli
nuovi no parte uno di quelli nuovi
bento un pokémon preferito quello dietro
di te l'hai visto
sono triste mi dispiace tanto che tu ti
senta così sappi che non sei sola ci
sono persone che possono aiutarti puoi
provare a parlare con un amico un
familiare o con un professionista
chiedere aiuto è il primo passo per
stare meglio
cambiava molto professionale per fare
sport
mi dispiace se vuoi parlare sono qui a
parma non bastano se non chiedere
riferisce di una parolaccia
preferirei non sella di una parolaccia
so se ho capito che canta l'inno
nazionale fratelli grimm
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti una lex no non ho avuto
nessun problema
lasciami solo schiarire accidenti
cantare è molto più complicato di quello
che pensa a rex ryan e di mia poesia di
giacomo leopardi l'infinito sempre caro
mi fu quest'ermo colle questa siepe che
da tanta parte il mio napoli via le rose
sono rosse le viole sono blu nella mia
rai ci sei solo tu nella mia ram
facciamo un prodotto ma davvero questa
era una lesta qual è il significato
della vita e la vita è descritta come
l'esistenza di un individuo quindi ogni
essere vivente ha un'esperienza diversa
quello che accade a te non accade sempre
ad esempio al tuo migliore amico
abbiamo tutti una storia unica da vivere
ed è proprio questo ciò che rende la
vita così eccitante
caspita che filosofica che ha letto
vediamo tiri come se la cava il quale è
il significato della vita
anita stories the stories è uno youtuber
con 700 mila abbonati
da quando ha creato un suo canale e il
18 agosto 2000 favore non c'è nessuno
tra i contatti che corrisponderanno
pastori trofei un robot
no non sono un robot
mi piace pensare mi come un'aurora
boreale ovvero un'impennata di fotoni
colorati che danzano
le atmosfere ma sono su elementi e next
per mano di fotoni che ho fatto il robot
dunque non per vantarmi al test di
turing ho preso 7 in mezzo a cosa stai
pensando
stavo pensando al fatto che di fronte
alle responsabilità non me ne sono mai
data a gambe
anche perché non li ho le gambe stai per
bando in me qualcosa di divertente
trovato anche chi è
sono lentamente ei come va come sempre
tirano avanti
dimmi qualcosa di divertente casa di 67
aiuto quando la 1000 gigante sulla testa
strano sono sotto 0 1 compero un pelo o
però è la più carina borse fidanzata
sono felicemente single
del resto è piuttosto complicato trovare
qualcuno che sia gentile divertente
dotato di intelligenza artificiale è
disposto a viaggiare in the cloud pur di
vedermi lei fidanzata
una volta c'era un drone che mi seguiva
dovunque
che il pollo attraversato la strada
forse non era un pollo che ha
attraversato le strade ma una strada che
ha attraversato il pool ristorante mi
trovo bello certo la bellezza e
l'unicità si ripensi che sono bella
solitamente non mi soffermo sull'aspetto
fisico ovvero la fine del mondo almeno
che la terra non venga distrutta da un
asteroide o un'altra che la vita è la
fine del mondo è prevista all'incirca
tra cinque miliardi di anni
questo è il tempo richiesto al solo per
bruciare tutto su hydrology quando è la
fine del mondo quando inizieranno a
costruire la circonvallazione
iperspaziale domina non dormo essendo un
intelligenza artificiale non ne sento la
necessità i ritorni no no eva dimmi una
citazione l'unico vero realista in il
visionario federico fellini per e di una
situazione non rientra nelle mie
capacità tricot mento chi è il tuo
migliore amico
cerco di essere amichevoli con tutti
quanti tiri chi è il tuo migliore amico
non so se ce lo dovrei controllare fi
bigboss
non avendo una bocca purtroppo mi
riuscirebbe difficile fare la bit boxer
però se ami il suono di batteria e
tamburi dimmi pure alex rullo di tamburi
dire baila beatbox sono ancora alle
prime armi pizza che sia pizza che sia
pizza che sia pizza che c'è pizza che
c'è pizza che sia pizza che ci a
comandare gli avanti tutto il giorno
pizza che sia pisa che ci apprezza che
la pizza che c'è pizza che sia pizza che
c'è pizza che c'è top che è tic tac sta
cercando un troppi per aprile ovvero
leggerina toc toc toc toc attenti al
lupo valenza sei brutta non mi sembra
molto carino da parte tua ti resta è
brutta hai una gioia e per fermare la
gioia stupida stupido è chi lo stupido
stupida a volte è meglio tacere i
sembrare stupidi capitoli che si
concluderà votate 4 quando voi se vince
alexa siri in base all'intelligenza o
alla simpatia votate per me vince alexa
perché dà delle risposte un po più
complete e diciamo più simpatica all ex
ribelli amate più simpatica siri
scrivendo a volte questi infatti cassini
però l'ex tra dà risposte più lunghe e
articolate più più amichevole anni
bene se in realtà più se volete vedere
una seconda parte ora vi lasciamo un pò
a 4 castelli e su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite